now in a strange universe by I myself
feminine Hansa I don't see my particular
abilities being all that great because
all I'd be able to do is enhance your
interest in the subscribe button for the
new old review the pressing of which
will grant you regular hunt onto content
uploaded straight into your YouTube feed
hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today we will be beginning
a detailed journey through hunter hunter
by taking some time to examine the
individual known affinities as well as
they users commencing with enhancement
now if for whatever reason you're not
too familiar or not too solid on the
concept of men in general then I highly
recommend you watch this video first
because a lot of what I'm going to talk
about here relies on some basic assumed
knowledge of net it won't be too much
just simple things like or manipulation
as well as foundational principles but
assuming that you're a complete hunt on
to boss by now we are going to dive
straight into enhancement so this is by
far the most basic net affinity of the
six categories so I figured that it's a
nice one to start with and basically the
objective of this art form is to have
its users wield their aura to increase
the general strength or durability of
either an object or parts of the users
body so as a result the large majority
of enhancers that we encounter in the
series are going to fall into a very
simple category of brawlers and as such
it can be something of a common belief
that enhances don't actually need to
develop a unique hearts or of their own
and they can excel by applying the basic
and advanced principles of Nan just to a
significantly more potent degree than
those without the enhancement affinity
and while there is a great deal of truth
in that thought it is nowhere near the
be all and end all of enhancement which
we will explore but for now I should
also point out that of the six
categories enhancement is certainly the
most balanced because it allows users to
have roughly equitable attack and
defensive capabilities because the logic
is the stronger that you can make your
attack then in theory you should be able
to defend using that exact same horror
manipulation just distributed
differently however to counter that
whole point about balanced enhancement
is by far the least versatile known
ability so while it may provide a user
with some general comfort in non-combat
it's not going to be the discipline that
will grant to use a maximum reward for
the art form which is why I would argue
that enhancement is best used in
conjunction with one of the other
affinities and speaking of according to
the nen ring enhancement is boarded by
omission and transmutation with a
mission being another fairly basic
mechanic on its own however in
combination with other affinities it
does become pretty phenomenal
and as for transmutation this is most
certainly the best
natural enhancers because it provides
them with that much-needed versatility
should they choose to invoke it which to
be fair they may not because if we
examine the ever reliable source is the
horny battle clown Hisoka his name
personality analysis scheme defines
enhancers as simple and determined often
completely subject to their emotions and
very straightforward fighters who are
unlikely to think too far beyond the
simple rush of battle and as for whether
or not that's true well let's find out
and obviously we should start by
examining our primary protagonist mr.
gon who is an example of enhancement
incarnate and his signature hearts who
rock from the chitron concert reflects
this because this is one of those
situations that we're talking about by
defining rock as an inability doesn't
necessarily work because it could more
accurately be described as a combination
of the established principles of men in
essence rock sees gone perform a
supercharged version of Ko which is
allowed to exist because gone takes an
incredible risk in terms of the time he
needs to power it up but also in this
process he Foucault's any form of aura
defense so it's a gambit technique that
relies on defeating an opponent right
then and there
in addition to this they go and confer
the power up the code by building up his
ran but in the end what you do have is a
big ole punch show that if you get hit
by it doesn't really matter who you are
you're taking some pretty serious damage
and in fact most average people would
certainly be killed upon impact with it
so it's a very stock standard
enhancement maneuver really and to see a
similar example let's now turn to
another enhancer ANOVA game who godlike
and legendary figures assigned is quite
possibly the physically strongest
character that we have ever encountered
in the series and his grand attack is
known as Big Bang impact which similarly
to cons Rock has ever gained focuses
aura into a fist via KHOU and then he
very simply punches a target which
generates enough force to rival that of
a small missile and that seems pretty
phenomenal in comparison to rock but all
of this is made possible primarily
through vogons absurd based physical
strength as well as his profound mastery
of enhancement but also through a set of
restrictions on the attack itself which
Marchi implied can only be performed by
oof against right fist and it must be a
straight punch so there is very little
room for versatility with big bang
impact but at the same time versatility
is not necessarily the aim of the game
straightforward game if anything move
again is what I would call the ultimate
pure enhancer because his tragedy in
life is to tackle everything head-on and
force his way through with simple brute
strength and for an awfully long time to
be fair that strategy did work out
pretty
well for him but his demise at the hands
of crop oka really highlights the flaws
of pure enhancement because even if we
disregard change L move against simple
tactics could not stand up to a
competent end-user
capable of actually thinking and
strategizing enhancement isn't always
about fists based attacks though and to
briefly examine that I now present to
you a bunny named Vermont I guess more
accurately a chimera ant enhancer used
his brief time on this planet for the
simple task of creating a technique
known as feather blades which as the
name implies enhances his feathers to
the point where they become super sharp
and super strong so very basic
enhancement and effective although not
quite effective enough a more
interesting in diverse use of
enhancement can be found in the
character of pom Siberia though who most
people often forget is a natural
enhancer and that does make some degree
of sense because her two most memorable
abilities being wink blue and Merman
clairvoyance do not appear to invoke
enhancement at all and to be honest it's
quite difficult to discern exactly how
she does achieve these and if I didn't
know for a fact that she was an enhancer
I'd say that it was specialization but
in terms of enhancement pom shines
through the use of the black widow
hatsue which is a very fancy way of
saying that she can enhance her hair and
wrap it around herself to act as body
armor which then allows palm to focus on
devoting the majority of her aura to
attacking rather than using a
substantial amount of its defend which
is very handy for her because she
doesn't quite have that raw physicality
that a new vogue in wood so it's a much
more sophisticated enhancement strategy
than the more reckless invitations of
going into vogue in and I should say
that while unconfirmed it is also
incredibly likely the Black Widow
requires palm to use manipulation to
shape her hair which is a pretty
fantastic example of where I believe
enhancement is best applied which is in
conjunction with another discipline
enhancement does continue to get more
diverse in this sir and the
comparatively recent character of bill
shows us this as he is a rare individual
in the world who is a natural enhancer
with a supportive type answer his
ability known as erica ron allows him to
accelerate the growth of the living
being so for example he can make a seed
sprout into a plant within mere minutes
but he can also use his ability on
humans to directly enhance the
individual nand power so bill is the
kind of enhancer who is best kept out of
combat but a huge benefit to any
partnership or group dynamic very
interestingly though we also have an
example of at least one enhancer who
does not appear to use his natural
affinity at all which is isaac natural
and I guess I should say that Natura was
only revealed to be an enhancer
in a wide variety of hunt onto data
books and data sections available which
do you know sometimes contains some very
questionable information being
distributed without mostly effects names
but the fact that natural has been
stated to be an enhancer in multiple
incarnations of these makes me think
that here we should take it at face
value but it's interesting because
natural signature hunt through the 100
type Guan Yin Bodhisattva makes use the
mission manipulation and transmutation
to operate so emitting the statue of
Guan Yin manipulating its hand movements
and transmuting the aura into a bar
style attack that you see in Xero hand
strangely enough though enhancement is
not officially credited at all in this
ability although I could see a use for
it in regards to beefing up the base
strength of the statue
but then again enhancement doesn't
really get used on nen constructs all
that often and it seems to be almost
exclusively applied to objects that
already exist and of course people that
already exist so like guiteau's basic
enhancement moves with the spinning tops
for example these tops are regular
objects that Guiteau turns into deadly
deadly attacking devices but off the top
of my head I can only really think of
one confirmed example of a character
that makes use of enhancement to juice
up an end construct which comes to us in
the form of Castro who was able to use
enhancement on his doppelganger via the
true tiger bite fist attack although
interesting thing about Castro now that
we've brought him up look natural is not
the only example of an enhancer who
chose to specialize in other disciplines
with the other notable individual being
Castro although Castro is known as ro
and he certainly does not succeed to
anywhere near that degree Castro is
actually something of an unfortunate
individual who was able to create a
really cool ability through a
combination of conjuration and
manipulation however those affinities
happen to lay the furthest away from
enhancement on the nen rank by a
specialization of course and so as a
result Castro was never really able to
reach the full potential of anything
really he was naturally stunted in terms
of conjuration at manipulation and he
never focused on enhancement beyond a
very simple attack powering up his hands
so as much as I advocate for mixing
enhancement with other affinities in
order to get maximum usage out of it
Castro is the ultimate example of that
just going wrong because he did more or
less abandon his own specialty and
furthermore Castro was also an enhancer
that doesn't necessarily fit his sokka's
personality test because he's something
of a Trixie being not at all
simple-minded which you know it doesn't
necessarily prove he soaked as thisis
wrong and in fact if anything Castro is
the exception that proves the rule
because his personality
just plain incompatible with the art of
enhancement now for some other
personalities who were tough to look
past we have u P the Chimera ant well
God who presented himself as a very
simple individual but one capable of
great growth
he was a natural enhancer but I also
don't think it's really fair to examine
the Royal Guards too closely because
their aptitude for nen makes a natural
affinity pretty pointless unless of
course it is specialization the thing is
you P had the sheer quantity of aura and
natural talent to make devastating use
of any discipline and in fact the only
confirmation we have on how any of his
abilities worked is that rage blast is a
clear example of a mission metamorphosis
and rage incarnate are much more
difficult to diagnose but I feel like a
combination of enhancement and
manipulation makes a lot of sense in
regards to how he changed and powered up
his body turning to the Phantom troupe
once again though and they have two more
enhancers that are not groove again
being thinks and Nobunaga now thinks
makes a lot of sense because his ability
the Ripper cyclotron sees him increased
the power of his eventual punch with
each time he winds up his arm in a
clockwise direction and this actually
bears a lot of similarities to Khan's
rock technique because Fink's actually
needs to take usually quite a decent
amount of time to charge his attack with
15 rotations being required to destroy
the body of a particularly resilient
chimera and it's a fascinating use of
enhancement though because rather than
performing in advanced ko it's more like
thinks has set himself an N limitation
needing to perform the rotations to
access great power which is hugely
advantageous in this case because it
means that he can still keep up a great
natural defense whilst being afforded
the opportunity to attack viciously and
as for Nobunaga he definitely fits the
bill of an enhancer being an honorable
warrior type and even though we don't
have a solid example of him applying the
affinity they imagine that he would use
it in a much more precise manner than
the pure punch bombs that are gone Ubu
keen and Fink's and just to round out
our natural enhances we also have Wayne
gone and killaz initial teacher of nen
he just so happens to be an enhancer
which doesn't initially seem to fit he
soaked his personality branding although
to be fair we never really learned quite
enough about wing the one I find the
most fascinating though is that
according to the official hunt haunted
honor book Maha zoldak is an enhancer
which should raise big question marks
for those of you familiar with the
abilities of the zoldak family who
operate exclusively as transmuter zon
manipulators so basically every
Whitehead zoldak is a transmuter and
every black-haired one is a manipulator
and I guess maja has
yeah so that might give him some comedic
license to be a bit different but I just
find it fascinating that he's the old
one out when every known generation
below him subscribes to the classic
zoldak standard and there you have it
fairly detailed overview of enhancement
as well as natural enhancers no it's not
a simple case of saying that enhances
are all brute force combatants although
admittedly a lot of the prominent uses
in the series do subscribe to this
labeling I maintain that enhancement is
best used in combination with other
sectors of the nin ring and it can also
be applied purely in a supportive nature
so there is much more versatility in
this art than many give it credit for
although to be fair that versatility
isn't taken advantage of by most basic
enhancers so for now enhances of hunt
hunter I salute your broad simplicity
but what do you guys think please do
leave your thoughts on enhancement in
the comments below or even join my
discord server and if you're keen for
more hunt onto content and please do go
and check out some of my other videos or
even subscribe to the channel for
regular hunt hunter Glory delivered
straight until YouTube feed but for now
this has been the New World review and
I'll see you next time